For people living in hurricane or tornado country,...
...a simple weather app does little good in the event of a major storm.
A good extreme weather app to start with is Radar Cast Pro,...
...two dollars in the app store for iPhones only.
The app gives you the option of checking maps and satellites.
Users also appreciate how the app will forecast the weather patterns an hour out.
For more serious storm watchers, try downloading Radar Scope.
This ten-dollar app works on both iPhones and Androids...
...and gives you the most precise and accurate storm data available.
Handy color codes are used to indicate thunderstorm warnings,...
...tornadoes and flash flood warnings.
Finally, Radar Alive is a great app for people seriously interested in tracking storms...
...versus preparing for them.
It costs five bucks and runs only on Androids...
...and even offers a tool for actual weather chasers.
I hope these apps can keep you better prepared this hurricane season.